Speaker 1: . Let's talk next about some
incredible statements from Marjorie Taylor
GREENE and Tucker Carlson, both of which relate
to really serious political and media issues here
in the United States. First of all, radical,
repugnant, retrograde Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor GREENE complained that white
supremacists are being targeted when it comes to
mass shootings and domestic terror. You have
to see this to believe it. Marjorie Taylor
GREENE saying, you know, there's all these
different shooters and people doing bad stuff.
Some of them are black. And all this differs. And
they only want to target the white supremacists.
But as usual, it's all in the details. Listen to
what she had to say and then we'll talk about it.
Speaker 2: Dale, I mean, not sorry, not on the
jail, on the bill or this domestic terrorism
bill that came out for the Department of
Justice. And Jerry Nadler was on the House
floor and he was talking about white supremacy
and he was bringing up the terrible shooting
that happened in New York, but totally ignoring
the shooting that happened in California that I
think involved an Asian man that was the shooter,
totally ignoring the guy that drove his car,
a black man that drove his car for a Christmas
parade, killing people and was a racist himself,
completely ignoring, ignoring the black man that
did that New York subway shooting. You know,
these people are all guilty of these crimes.
And it's not about race. It shouldn't be about
race. But they're clearly racist as well. So white
supremacy shouldn't be the main target. We should
be more concerned about the illegal invasion
at the border. The prime happening every single
day on our streets, especially in cities like
Chicago. We should we should go after criminals
that break the law and not not pursue people
based on their skin color and how they vote.
Speaker 1: Okay. Now, of course, people aren't
being pursued by the criminal justice system
based on their skin color or how they vote.
But let's go through her claims one by one. She
mentions the California Asian man shooter that was
a shooting at a Taiwanese church in California.
One person was killed and five were wounded. It's
being investigated as a hate crime. And it was a
68 year old shooter motivated by the political
tensions between China and Taiwan, according to
authorities. There is no media narrative. There's
no political narrative in the United States
meant to activate or inspire any kind of tensions
between Chinese and Taiwanese people living in the
United States. You don't turn on Fox News and see
instigate of rhetoric about China and Taiwan such
that it would inspire shooters or whatever the
case may be. There's really no conversation to be
had there about American political discourse and
American media. We every once in a while will say,
oh, what? What is China thinking about when
it comes to Taiwan? But there is no big
media political story that in the United States
would have inspired this shooting. So why would
we be talking about it in the same terms? Then
Marjorie Taylor GREENE says, Well, the black man
that drove his car through a Christmas parade,
who was a racist? Okay. That's the Waukesha
Christmas parade attack from November. The driver
of an SUV plowed through a Christmas parade,
killed six people and injured 62. Terrible, tragic
incident. And we know that the perpetrator used
the same car to hit his ex-girlfriend 21 days
earlier. It's believed that the driver acted
alone, didn't even know anyone at the
parade, wasn't targeting any particular
group of people at the parade. The motive is not
equivalent. It is true that the guy was black.
It's true that he had a history of social media
posts that were anti-Semitic and advocated for
violence against Jews and white people and wrote
positive stuff about Hitler. Disgusting person,
no doubt about it. There is no evidence that the
incident is related to the ideology. There just
isn't any evidence. So why would we talk about
it in the same way? Lastly, Marjorie mentions the
New York subway shooting, who was also a black
man. That was six weeks ago. That's the 2022
New York City subway shooting. Reportedly, the
man is 60. A 62 year old black nationalist who put
on a gas mask, threw to smoke grenades and fired
more than 30 rounds from a handgun. Nobody died.
Fortunately, 29 were injured. Horrible incident.
The believed shooter would sometimes post
homophobic rants, online misogynistic rants,
online rants, targeting blacks, Hispanics, whites,
all sorts of different things. Anti-Semitic
believed link to black nationalism. Great talk
about. It. Talk about it. No manifesto, but we've
got some of this. A paper trail, for lack of a
better term. Black nationalism is a tiny movement.
There's no political party pushing the ideology of
black nationalism. That's it. I mean, I'm against
any violent movement, but there is no story here,
like what happened with the Buffalo shooter, where
we have seen years now of a combined political
and right wing media effort to talk about this
exact ideology that was in the manifesto. Lastly,
Marjorie mentions, and we should focus if we
really want to talk about this stuff, we should be
focusing on the illegal invasion at the border.
Immigrants documented and undocumented commit
crime in the United States at a lower rate than
domestically born citizens. So by the math of it,
that is not where you should focus if you want
to stop crime in the United States, because both
documented and undocumented immigrants commit
crime at a lower rate than American born
Americans, for lack of a better term. So it's
a weird thing to insert into the discussion. So
why are white supremacists being targeted? Well,
they're being targeted because law enforcement
and our intelligence agencies have
indicated this is a major threat.
And we quite literally found the manifesto of the
Buffalo shooter, where he was parroting the exact
stuff that we've been hearing on Tucker Carlson
and elsewhere for years now. That's why Marjorie.